[Music]
the sky is often unpredictable and
sometimes not even the biggest
specialist can explain what was caught
on camera from strange blue lights after
earthquakes to unexplainable Dementors
we only have one question what are these
things and why do they exist we made
this video in collaboration with our
good friends at the richest stay tuned
to the end to see their video halo
around the Sun this strange sky
phenomenon was spotted in the aftermath
of Hurricane sandy
back in 2012 it's one of the rarest and
unexplained mysteries out there confused
about what you see on this picture while
we don't know why this happens we can
definitely tell you what's happening in
more detail the redditor gave a really
good explanation of what's happening
with the Sun and the sky and we'll do
our best to summarize it in the best way
possible take a look at the Sun and
you'll see a 22 degree halo around it
along with the two plates shape trend
dogs on the left and the right the arc
is going through the Sun and sundogs is
known as the car helix circle and what
you see at the top of the
as a parabolic arc and then there's the
awesome upside-down rainbow Wichita's of
the Perry arc
even ahead of NASA's meteoroid
environment office said he's never seen
anything like this fascinating sight and
that it's an extremely rare once in a
decade event while we don't know why it
happened it was confirmed that it was
definitely a result of Hurricane sandy
while a halo around the Sun has
definitely been noted multiple times the
phenomenon would say
the elements at the same time is
extremely rare and still unexplained
turquoise lights in Norway
although Norway is known for their
colorful phenomenon of Northern Lights
this strange mystery has nothing to do
with it at least we think it deserts on
a cold winter's night back in 2009 the
Norwegian meteorological institute's
phone lines went crazy after observers
spotted this strange circles light in
the night sky it definitely looks like a
pathway to something but the question is
to watch the light appear for 2 to 3
minutes before disappearing like nothing
happened
reports were spotted from multiple
places around her way and everyone said
the same thing they saw a large ring
which spread out and sent a turquoise
beam down to earth the site is
definitely fascinating but no one has
been able to identify why it happened in
the first place the strange phenomenon
is still a mystery that not even
meteorologists astronomers or armed
forces could solve whether this was a
UFO a missile test or something else no
one knows why it appears the theories
for the strange phenomenon play
this was a rocket but this could also be
a message from the extraterrestrial life
the light hasn't appeared since then but
it seems like it startled several people
and made them feel uneasy they want
answers and we do too can you explain
why this strange phenomenon actually
happens let us know in the comments blue
lights on September 8th and 2017 an
earthquake of the eight points new
magnitude struck Mexico it was the
strongest earthquake the country has
seen in decades
along with destroying properties and
causing disruption it took the lives of
at least 58 people
and triggered a tsunami warning for at
least eight countries but the most
powerful earthquake it didn't only leave
its mark on the ground the earthquake
sped off what's known as earthquake
lights in the sky they were first
recorded by a Twitter user he was
completely dumbfounded by this
phenomenon although it's guaranteed
these fascinating lights were caused by
the earthquakes they have never actually
been explained what are these strange
Rison and why did they happen in the
first place seismologists also known as
people who study Earth's energy waves
said the scene lights have never been
proven and could very well be related to
electricity one explanation behind this
phenomenon is that it's a result of
power supplies being hit and triggering
small explosions in electric generators
it's strange that this phenomenon has
actually occurred before but the reason
behind the earthquake rights is thought
provoking and largely still unexplained
then maybe they're not that bad
a geologist stated that these lights in
the sky could be an early warning sign
of an approaching earthquake that would
make sense
however these lights occurred after the
earthquake de mentor now let's move on
to a very serious discussion when it
comes to unexplained mysteries in the
sky this one is very hard to believe and
it left the internet completely shocked
if you got soul-sucking and Happiness
destroying Dementors
only existed in the Harry Potter series
you were wrong although we doubt anyone
would want to see the soul-sucking
creatures in real life a Dementor
missile Isis actually spotted Harry
Potter fans this one's for you
the internet went into a frenzy when
someone posts a picture of this weird
thing floating in the sky it's shaped
exactly like a diamond or isn't it this
strange thing was originally spotted in
Zambia but the news of it spread all
around the world and everyone had a few
questions they needed answers to see a
good mentor is nothing to be excited
about but of course since the world of
Harry Potter is very much fictional the
news of this phenomenon was extremely
exciting however the news has Simpson
been debunked as a simple pipe that's
been digitally added to the picture or
at least that's what we think we do have
a few questions and we're looking for
answers when can we buy Dementor kites
and most importantly where the picture
first appear no one's quite sure what
the deal is behind the Dementor in the
sky mystery
what if Dementors really do exist in
real life Flying Spaghetti Monster when
we don't get an official explanation for
the mysteries we see in nature we're
officially allowed to give them our own
nicknames or at least that's the rule of
the Internet this phenomenon is known as
the Flying Spaghetti Monster and it was
spotted over Interstate 80 in Nevada
County
strange sky monster looks like a mix of
a dragon and an octopus and the picture
was captured by Margaret Porter who was
on her way to see her son there's not a
lot we actually know about this
phenomenon but since Margaret claims she
didn't really know how to use the camera
in the first place we can guarantee this
wasn't really photoshopped but Margaret
didn't even know what she captured in
the first place as she was driving to
pick up her son she was caught in the
storm and she was so fascinated by the
rain she wanted to capture it on her
phone luckily her son's taught her how
to use the iPhone camera which is what
she used to document the rain her son
was actually the one who noticed the
octopus monster the National Weather
Service gave a statement on this
phenomenon saying it was most likely
result of a turbulent storm however many
aren't convinced and claimed that the
sky creature has a spiritual message and
a warning for the future of this world
hey guys thanks for watching if you
liked this video then be sure to check
out ten natural phenomenons that baffled
scientists by the richest make sure to
comment share and subscribe to their
Channel
[Music]